[Musique]
danilo est pas là moulins ont trouvé une
façon originale de soutenir les artistes
émergents le couple a décidé de
convertir une partie de sa superbe
demeure de style renaissance française
en centre d'artistes nouveau genre qui
ont acheté la maison aussi je pense
daniel avait l'idée d'en faire notre
lieu de résidence mais on avait aussi
l'idée qu'une idée est venue assez
rapidement que c'est un espace qu on
voulait qu'ils souhaitent disponible
aussi pour les gens de montréal non mais
c'était trop bien pour nous l'un des
enfants sans papiers on n'est pas dans
l'idée de tenir des grandes réceptions
donc on fait un bel espace passionnés
d'art et de culture c'est dans
l'informatique qu'ils ont fait fortune
après avoir créé des bourses et
scientifique investi dans le domaine
communautaire et financer l'achat
d'oeuvres d'art pour des musées le
couple souhaitait étendre son action
philanthropique différemment on a
découvert le milieu était vraiment
belton le milieu des galeries lieu des
conservateurs le milieu des artistes les
plus qu'on aimait beaucoup c'est la
possibilité d'être un contact avec ces
jeunes
ces gens là ce sont des artistes comme
jamais des lauriers qui termine
actuellement sa maîtrise la prestigieuse
université yale et qui réside et
travaille à la casa quand elle revient à
montréal je trouve que le support de
daniel et paul pierce il ya d'autres
personnes qui le font de manière
différente mais ça permet une
spontanéité c'est comment je fasse ce
projet là je m'inscris on maîtrise je
n'y a pas de programme pour cela depuis
son ouverture en juillet 2020 projet
kazakh est situé sur la rue de
l'esplanade à montréal face au mont
royal accueillie 14 expositions mettant
en vedette 50 artistes et qui ont été
vues par près de 3500 visiteurs un
projet entièrement privé réalisé sans la
de l'état dans le milieu des
technologies j'ai beaucoup travaillé
toute ma vie
c'est dans un autre milieu mais je vois
le même la même passion le même
enthousiasme la même détermination que
les personnes qui s'interrogent beaucoup
qui réfléchissent qui sont vraiment
engagés dans toutes les espèces de
société non ça fait donc je vais
vraiment des
rencontres enrichissantes
la prochaine exposition au projet casa
débute le 20 janvier prochain ça
s'appelle en constante transformation
c'est l'occasion de découvrir les
installations performances et vidéos de
neuf artistes en début de carrière
d'échanger avec eux et de découvrir ce
lieu d'exception sinai bay alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal